bonsoir pour obtenir le 22 à asnières
comme le racontait fernand raynaud il ne
faut plus appeler new york il ya
longtemps d'ailleurs il ya déjà un petit
moment
fini aussi le temps où le où l'on se
taper sur les cuisses quand la france du
général de gaulle décidé de construire
des ordinateurs et puis un jour
peut-être on ne regardera plus avec un
air béat les japonais les américains
avec leurs gadgets vous avec qui
consiste à les relier un téléphone et un
téléviseur pour donner des informations
bientôt nous aurons ça aussi chez nous
c'est la télématique voilà les trois
domaines traités ce matin au conseil des
ministres pour marquer encore une fois
la volonté du gouvernement non seulement
de rattraper son retard mais d'être dans
les tous premiers dans le développement
des activités nouvelles grâce à une
technologie en pointe et bien maîtrisé
avec activité nouvelle qui conformément
aux voeux de monsieur giscard d'estaing
sont économes en énergie ça c'est
important
et puis créatrice d'emplois nouveaux
cela aussi c'est très important
ainsi pour le téléphone alors que nous
étions au dernier rang des pays
européens
en 1974 le retard doit être comblé
totalement en 1982 mais déjà ça va
beaucoup mieux
il y avait douze lignes téléphoniques
pour 100 habitants
il ya cinq ans il y en a aujourd'hui 25
il y avait six millions d'abonnés à peu
près en 74 13 millions aujourd'hui plus
de 19 millions dans trois ans cet effort
a permis le développement d'une
industrie des télécommunications qui se
situe parmi les plus avancées a dit le
secrétaire d'état aux ptt norbert segard
et puis qui est aussi exportatrices
l'industrie informatique française est
elle aussi en plein essor on dit qu'elle
est créatrice d'emplois à un niveau
élevé
malheureusement et ça ça n'est pas dit
dans le communiqué du conseil des
ministres
on manque d'ingénieurs et daf un
informaticien c'est peut-être pour cela
qu'un important programme d'initiation
et de formation à l'informatique dans
les collèges lycées et universités a été
décidée dès le mois d'octobre prochain
130 lycée recevront des micro
ordinateurs
enfin ya donc la télématique ce mot
barbare parce que nouveau à propos
duquel michel chevalet va nous deux
et l'éclairage nécessaire la télématique
vous savez et bien c'est le mariage
entre le téléphone la télévision et
l'ordinateur et un mariage finalement
très réussie puisque déjà et bien on
voit apparaître des enfants les nouveau
nés alors les voici
alors tout d'abord nous sommes à la
maison nous sommes chez nous et bien
chez nous le cadran téléphonique va être
remplacé et voyez par ce clavier à
touches et à partir de 1981 3 millions
de postes comme celui ci seront
installés chez les abonnés ensuite et
bien toujours la maison il va y avoir et
il est déjà en service devront présenter
l'annuaire électronique en quelque sorte
deux parties premièrement vous voyez un
écran de télévision sur lequel
s'affichent les renseignements que l'on
trouve habituellement dans la mer et
puis un clavier pour l'interroger à la
une précision à partir de 1980 les deux
cent cinquante mille abonnés d'ille et
vilaine et bien posséderont un annuaire
téléphonique qui sera mis gratuitement à
leur disposition une variante également
de ce système c'est le télé tel cette
fois ci c'est l'écran de votre
téléviseur relié à un clavier spécial et
sur l'écran du téléviseur apparaîtront
différents enseignements comme par
exemple si vous aimez la bourse les
cours de la bourse ou bien les horreurs
de chemin de fer ou bien les programmes
des spectacles toujours à la maison nous
aurons un appareil semblable à celui ci
c'est un télécopieur autrement dit nous
voyons en ce moment je suis en train
d'acheminer ni plus ni moins qu'un
document c'est à dire une lettre un
correspondant située à plusieurs
centaines de kilomètres de distance
et c'est en quelque sorte la
démocratisation des télécopies puisque l
appareil mieux vous sera proposé pour
2000 francs c'est en quelque sorte et
bien le courrier électronique mais le
plus intéressant peut-être c'est à dire
ici au niveau du bureau de poste au
niveau du guichet alors vous imaginez
que nous sommes dans un bureau de poste
voilà en face de madame il y à un
terminal d'ordinateurs elle procède en
direct avec l'ordinateur les opérations
s'est dit qu'en ce moment je lui ai
demandé sur mon livret de caisse
d'epargne d'effectuer un retrait de 2000
francs et voyez que son oliveraie il y
as en bas une piste magnétique sur
lequel sont portés des renseignements et
notamment la position de mon compte
vous continuez madame elle interroge
donc l'ordinateur l'ordinateur dit que
l'on peut effectuer ce retrait et
regardez bien la suite
mantes intéressante le document est
avalée et immédiatement en direct et
bien mon compte en quelque sorte est
mise à jour rio risque alors ensuite eh
bien on peut procéder
voilà même type d'opération avec vous le
savez les chèques postaux je vous
signale qu'à nantes déjà des bureaux
sont équipés avec ce système qu'à la fin
du mois
l'opération démarrera à paris et qu'en
dix mille bureaux de poste seront ainsi
équipés voilà donc la grande révolution
de la télématique dans le domaine des
ptt voyez une révolution qui avance à
grands pas alors